I'm turning my attention back to the El
Salvador president actually after we did
the segment on him yesterday I noticed that
President bouquet in El Salvador tweeted out
the bit from this show and and quoted the segment
and then I went to the president's Twitter page
I said oh that's kind of cool he tweeted out
the segment and then I saw he had another video
and this is kind of the answer to the propaganda
video of the MS-13 gangsters that he put out you
know president bouquet has arrested thousands and
thousands of these gangsters I think there's 65
000 of them now locked up these guys look
like demon bugs they've got weird green
face tattoos and he's humiliating them and he's
sent the Army out to deal with the crime problem
and reduce the murder rate by 58 well now here's
the other side of that not just the Doom and Gloom
and fire and brimstone we're gonna get you bad
guys here's the hopeful message for the rest
of the country I will translate by reading the
text on the screen because my Spanish is no good
president bouquet standing out talking to his
troops in a field for eight months we've been
fighting this war against the gangs and thank God
we're winning this is a very surprising victory
that is nearly within our grass let it be clear
that the glory is for God and it is God's glory
we humans are lucky to be instruments of God
all of us to bring peace Liberty and happiness
to the Salvadoran people these values were
probably not strong in this land and were
strong in other languages and that's why those
lands grew and became they are losing those values
previously were degraded in our
country are now the most important ones
just take a look at yourself
how could a nation not rise up with values such
as these How could a nation not rise up when it
puts God first and then puts in the hard work
and effort with these kinds of values beautiful
political science students will
be studying this speech history
students will be studying this speech years
from now this is beautiful simple and true
the president of El Salvador sounds
like an American founding father
in that speech more so he sounds
like Governor Bradford Governor
Winthrop were some of the very earliest
Americans who helped to build our country
they kept it very simple it's just like the
policy what's the policy you want to fight
crime lock up the criminals you want to build a
great nation put God first everything else will
follow seek ye first the kingdom of heaven
all the other Goods will follow after that
president bukele he says in our country these
values had been degraded other nations had
those values that's why those other nations
became great and now those other nations are
turning away from those values who's
he talking about he's talking about us
and he's showing you something beautiful
that happens throughout history and that
you see certainly in the history of Salvation
certainly you see this throughout the Bible
that very often it can be small Mighty
groups small Underdog groups who put on
the armor of God who can astound and frankly
embarrass the supposedly far greater Nations
which have profited profited from God's grace
and then turned their backs on him go on done
something else doesn't turn out well for those
countries doesn't turn out well for those Empires
he says that line How could a nation with
these values not rise up not become great
and not it's very very simple I'm not saying that
it's easy but it's simple president buchelli's
speech here could have been given not just by the
founding fathers or the early Colonial Americans
could have been given by any great leader
in our civilization going back to Antiquity
all the way up until about 20 years ago now we
don't hear these speeches very often but it's
pretty simple stuff folks these big political
problems that our opponents want to pretend
are so complicated oh well you know gender and
sex it's so it's not complicated men or men and
women are women well you know the issue of
reproductive freedom and no it's not don't
kill babies it's really simple well the issue
of immigration is so complicated Ronald Reagan
said illegal immigration is not complicated it's
illegal stop it crime is not complicated lock up
the criminals build more prisons lock them
up punish them harder you'll get less crime
how do we have a great country look toward God
look to the source and Summit of goodness himself
being himself you'll have a good country you look
away from God you're going to have a bad country
it's very very simple so the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it become
a member use code Knowles can wlas a check out
for two months free on all annual plans [Music]
ha